ah ah ah non pas du tout
[Musique]
si on déclarait des films d'amour dans
lesquels les preuves de fraterniser
ensemble ça m'étonnerait que la paire
reviendrait peut-être qu'on aurait dû
faire un film d'une heure et demie sur
des colombes qui traversent le ciel bleu
et tout le monde serait centièmes s'agit
[Musique]
il en est actuellement mais c'est une
question de budget c'est pas une
question de politique ou de faisabilité
c'est une question d'argent
[Musique]
les cinémas devant lequel on s'endort et
c'est un cinéma qui ne le seront pas et
qui est un cinéma qui qu'ils ne puissent
en effet et qui est indolore ce qui
n'est pas la fonction même de l'art
ah non pas du tout vu le contenu ça
m'étonnerait
[Musique]
c'est formidable que ce type là se
soient battus il a fait son film avec
très peu d'argent
il s'est vraiment battu personne n'y
croyait personne n'en voulait il l'a mis
en scène il s'est vraiment acharnée
pendant plusieurs années alors que
personne ne l'a aidé aujourd'hui il va
aux oscars respect
[Musique]